So, here is my code for the class movie, and behind it, is hidden
the other programming file, where we have
defined multiple instances of the class movie, namely
Toy Story and Avatar. So, what I will do, is go back to my
code for the class movie, and define
a new function or method there called, show_trailer.
Now, each instance method, whether it be init
or show_trailer takes the first argument as, self. So
I will add that. All, show_trailer has to do,
is open the web browser, with the correct URL.
And the link or the URL, is stored in
the instance variable. trailer_youtube_url. The way to
access this instance variable, is through the self keyword.
One last thing I need to make this code
work, is to import web browser.
There, let me go ahead and save this file. Now that we have defined
the method, show_trailer. The next thing for us to do, is to call this method,
using our other programming file. So I will go there, and here, I already
have the instance or object called, Avatar.
So I will use it, Avatar,
to call the show_trailer method. I'm
going to go ahead and save this file.
And then I will run it.
[MUSIC]
Wow, that was outstanding.